[Music]
a massive drug smuggling tunnel was just
found
linking tijuana all the way to san diego
oh whoa
it is a big ass
are getting really good because before
it used to just be like oh under the
wall
now it's like 200
under the state
directly to bell flower
can you imagine like i mean that's a lot
of dirty huge food how did they do that
and hide that whole situation
i don't know maybe they hired north
koreans so it's
[Laughter]
it's about the distance of like five or
six football fields they said they did
it to code too you see a lot of them
it's an ocean
yeah they got hard
they really want a drinking code so it's
like wait a minute yeah they have hvac
in there with the phone yeah they got ac
everything so the cool thing is it
starts uh obviously on the mexico side
but then it ends underneath like a
warehouse in san diego
i don't even see people like getting
getting out wow and there's these little
like there's little access points in
other warehouses for like guards to go
down ladders how long do you think that
took them to make how many miles i don't
know but how long do you think it was
operating you know if they if you could
build a tunnel from tijuana san diego i
think you deserve to like self-driving
yeah how long
you earned it how long is that walk like
you get a pass dude san diego to tijuana
because like a drive is like less than
30 minutes right well if they said it's
about like six football fields that's
what like 600 700 yards
that's more than what the elon musk is
trying to do with this hyperloop right
you know elon should just be high and
wake up
do a collab or something remember when
we went to uh the border of north korea
and then um we saw the tunnels that the
north koreans made into south korea
they did a better job in mexico but back
over there it was like a it was like a
little it looked like a cave like it
went more and more narrow yeah and it
got narrow and i was like man they don't
work as good as this because these guys
they have a frame they have a [ __ ]
ventilation pipe like damn dude
you know i just i just crossed from
mexico to
from back to san diego last week because
i was doing this charity thing and like
the line to go through the border was
like four hours yeah it's a pain in the
ass just got the tunnel like you know i
know the tunnel's here let me just go
fast you should just got on a hoverboard
a bird scooter you should just yeah keep
that tunnel and make it the fast track
honestly the crazy thing is when you
find tunnels like this uh it's america's
job to fill the american side with
concrete yeah mexico doesn't have to do
nothing that's stupid they should just
keep it open and make it our tsa
precheck
[ __ ] global entry that [ __ ] dude
mark can't get in though he can't get in
you know it's kind of crazy though it's
like we're
the americans are so
i'm saying it as an american right so
we're so obsessed with this idea of
border control and board security and
making walls but these guys are already
like tunneling under these right so this
goes underneath the exact wall yeah i'm
like how many of these other tunnels
haven't been found that are being used
like probably through texas [ __ ] new
mexico like all across the border they
find i think they find them all the time
but this particular one was just like a
huge find so it was newsworthy but
imagine how many they find that if they
could not tell the press of course
you're not gonna say nothing maybe this
happened during the trump administration
where the cartels were like build a wall
i'll build a tunnel
the drug the drug dealers or the drug
runners that did get caught using it
were all socal residents too
do you think like the like the homeland
security agents when they find the
tunnel you think they're in a state of
disappointment like what the [ __ ] are
they doing or like amazes me like whoa
it's longer it gets even longer this is
pretty cool
i think the way they found it too is
that they found one of those warehouses
first
they were tracking these uh drug
smugglers and then they were tracking
their cars and then they finally like
found the point where they were all kind
of originating from or going to yeah so
they go to this warehouse and then they
just find the the ladder in the hole and
i think that's how they found they
didn't put the rug over it
[Laughter]
you gotta cover it hair skin that's
where they [ __ ] them in the middle of
the wheel
[Laughter]
bart's just over there in the corner
like twiddling his thumbs like that
don't look over that way
that's where they [ __ ] up they forget
to dot their eyes
with a grandma
uh with a hot cocoa on a rocking chair
just chilling
like nothing to see here you know more
the more things you add to cover this
yeah
that's true
so what does this say about the war on
drugs already winning this war on drugs
or
dude there's no winning the war on
trucks
how long has it been for uh the 80s
right that's when they started yeah
man i think we're losing
there's a lot of people i know that are
on drugs so that side of is just so good
at clapping back at any kind of
increased regulation or increased like
enforcement they're just too good at
like okay we'll make it worse oh you
want to make weed legal and then you
think that's going to mess it up all
right fentanyl for everybody yeah
it's like dude look what's happening now
man it's just getting crazy and it feels
too good
all of it all of this like you just have
too good of a product man it's great
yeah it's it's insane they were able to
catch uh through this bust which if you
wouldn't even call it that yeah they
seized 1762 pounds of cocaine 165 pounds
of meth and 3.5 pounds of heroin in
connection with the investigation
yeah what do you think is our top seller
out of those three
what was their biggest weight oh no
those are all pretty addictive coke coke
yeah probably more the most popular
because they don't they don't smuggle
weed no more right yeah that's and the
thing is what and interesting we bring
up the war on drugs so because of weed
being legal weed was the harder thing to
smuggle because it weighed more and the
smells and all that so they're just like
thank god it's like i don't want to deal
with that [ __ ] exactly so you can you
could traffic way more cocaine than weed
in the same like packaging technique and
you know distribution everything's way
easier more profitable per ounce yeah
yeah exactly so what if you buy a plane
what happened
through the toilet
fit you cut the wings off you push it
down the top
and then you put the wigs back on
she gonna play with tuttle
the play just comes out of a warehouse
that's not suspicious like the bat plane
they should have turned into an airplane
hangar honestly they missed an
opportunity but then they're like why
are they fully taking off
from the hangar these guys are in the
wrong business because planes
they're expensive
yeah dude well i mean like okay she'll
make that whole list yeah this is the
ladder down to the tunnel dude a bear
skin really easily that's where the
abuelita could have been sitting yeah
yeah dude look how easy that is just
cover that [ __ ] up like nothing they
suck at [ __ ] hiding and the ladder's
sticking out they gotta hide the hole
better or you just put a bean bag you
know easy yeah
you have to drop it down they got too
comfortable i still don't know which
cartel is responsible for this tunnel
they i mean obviously they have like
obvious ones that are like they're maybe
the richest one yeah just look at the
board with the [ __ ] red strings on it
yeah
how many cartels are there that's a lot
quite a lot but what are your favorite
cartels let's go around
i'm hearing that in the top five reasons
to go to morongo voice
[Laughter]
arizona oh god they're scary dude
yeah i think they're all did you guys
continue watching um
yeah narcos after what's his name died
pablo died
because there's a few more episodes
where it starts to transfer into the
mexico side oh cool yeah but then it got
boring
because i thought it was good
[Laughter]
i didn't finish
do they have like a new like um like el
chapo type character that's as
charismatic as nah they're not
charismatic that's hard that that was a
really good uh pablo one she was so good
but apparently the medellin cartel pablo
and the whole people like those peoples
their notoriety is just blown up because
of the um dea cia or whatever all those
guys and then like um you know how
lately a lot of gangsters like to come
on uh podcasts and have conversations
and stuff and be like a rat uh right
right to themselves yeah
and uh a lot of top guys are coming out
saying like uh that was just because d.a
agents want to like be like look at what
i got i got this big [ __ ] criminal
but apparently they weren't
that big sounds like they're hating
because they're like the real big guy
he's like lying about a big fish
yeah the real big guys don't get caught
they're multi like they're they're
they're like they don't conclude you
don't even know their names
yeah he's like they own actual like
businesses like
chiquita banana oh that's like the uh
the what's it called the
telecommunications uh guru or not guru
but uh
the guy from you know the richest guy in
mexico carlos slim yeah slim how they
say like he's connected to it but they
can't they can't like uh
100
the richest guy in mexico 100 i didn't
say anything i'm not gonna say it yeah
right
but i mean it makes sense right yeah i
mean it does
i follow this up page on instagram i
think it's called like asian gangsters
or mods i love that page dude sickest
page yeah they have all these like
like triad yakuza guys that are arrested
in their 50s 60s and 70s yeah and on
paper they're just real estate
developers yeah but then when you read
the stuff they're charged with it's like
prostitution extortion drug like human
trafficking there's like holy [ __ ]
visually they look like regular like old
asian guys no tattoos they look like
dudes you could kick in a stomach 300
style and be like [ __ ] but then you'll
regret it afterwards because it's like
they have a whole army
but they look like geeks dude yeah they
look like dorks
like there was that one guy all right
you have to be nice to die tomorrow
he was like a california senator um
leland
oh yeah yeah he was working with the
shrimp boy to smuggle guns to the
philippines and rpgs and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] that and he was like one of the
biggest
proponents of uh anti-gun gun control
his name was shrimp boy no or that was
yeah
that's why you always you always got to
suspect the unexpected asian person yeah
and when people have like hardcore
stances because he was super against the
second amendment so that you increase
the price in the black market yeah so
which benefits him on the other side
you